now here
are five real-life case examples of
millennials who beat the odds and
developed and leveled up
during
the pandemic they basically they came
back from from the dead essentially and
they made a career out of themselves so
here are five stories these are real
life case examples you guys listening
this is like this is something that i
could potentially say your name at
something like this so these are regular
people who basically were struggling
they beat the odds and they leveled up
during the pandemic and there's a
message in all these five of these
stories and they're very relatable
number one you can always start over
it's not too late so here's a story so
before the pandemic you got a couple
called karen and sylvester acpon right
so they owed more than a hundred
thousand dollars collectively in student
loans i'm sure there's a lot of people
out there that understand where this
came from yeah and they were paying 4
200 bucks a month for a five-bedroom
house in california that ain't cheap
3200 for a five-bedroom house forty two
hundred forty two hundred yeah five
bedrooms five bedroom who knows anyway
they owed a lot of money they were
probably making decent money um but it
was all going to student loans and to
rent so
um
they had a kid there they're starting a
family
so
there's hope out there listen to what
they did here this is a little unique um
so they basically sold their house
they
they took the money and ran and they
lived out of out of an rv throughout the
entire pandemic and they've been
traveling the country so now they travel
the country
they earn money by blogging not sure how
much the money they make but also doing
social media campaigns very interesting
story they probably you know obviously
made it onto cnbc for this story right
here
uh and they paid off here's the silver
lining they paid off all their student
loans and now they're focusing on saving
investing and building wealth so
the moral of the story was
it's not too late to start over yeah
they were going down a path traditional
path you know starting a family living
in california spending 4 200 bucks a
month for a house 110 grand in student
loans to be exact uh and they said i
don't want to live this life and they
just sold everything sold their house
took the money and run got an rv started
making money doing something out of the
ordinary
and
now they've paid off over a hundred
thousand dollars in student loans and
they're actually beginning to save that
money to invest so
kudos
to the akpans they if they end up
hearing this shout out to you guys
traveling the country um
and paying off your student loans this
is something uh have you ever
considered traveling the country in an
rv dude i was wow that's a lot of
courage i mean because that's
yeah i mean that's kind of uncomfortable
though if you really think about it i
mean
that's a tiny space
for a while to live in and then there's
that fear of like okay we are actually
doing this we just sold out like there's
no stepping back but i mean look the
proof is in the pudding they paid off a
hundred and ten thousand dollars in
student loans clearly i think that's
actually ahead of the game sure and like
if they can handle that stress of like
living in close quarters and not having
a home and like hey hey bob or sylvester
oh let's uh love to come over
yeah i live in an rv now well i'll just
drive over to your house and hang out
your house yeah so great for them dude
more power to them i don't think a lot
of people would be able to do that and
they seem very happy look at those uh
beaming smiles right there there they go
um that's awesome that's awesome for
them dude a lot of people could not do
that just sell their home i mean how
about this flip it flip it okay
they don't do this yeah they're paying
their 4 200 bucks a month they're paying
their you know 2 000 a month in student
loans whatever the payment is
how long does that take before before
they get ahead do you know on average
that it takes about 18 to 20 years to
pay off student loan debt yeah they did
it in a year and a half yeah
that's called you gotta do what you
gotta do that's called um doing what
everybody else isn't willing to do
exactly yeah that's called living
a different type of vibe so you can live
the rest of your life the vibe that you
want to live dude that's the yeah that's
exactly the octopus respect to the ak
anyway number two of these five case
examples of real-life people doing
extraordinary things
uh is have a plan b that's number two so
a lady called destiny adams she works
for the state of michigan as a child
welfare specialist she was earning 60
g's a year
she says it's not the most exciting job
but it provides her with stability and
benefits like health insurance but she
could not get ahead so
enter the old-fashioned side hustle that
inspired her so what did destiny do she
operates now a youtube consulting
business and runs the
destiny hair collection a small business
selling wigs and hair extensions ladies
love their wigs and hair extensions just
look at janita a girl in our office
she's got probably a wig a week that she
wears here so now destiny's doing that
she basically says the additional income
stream provides peace of mind allows her
to live the type of life that she wants
it's
you know usually nine to five that's 40
hours a week you're making 60 grand
kudos to you you decide you start a side
hustle maybe that's an extra 10 20 grand
a year boom that cumulative effect now
three years in maybe you're making an
extra 50 grand maybe five years in
you're making 100 grand you quit your
job you focus on that full time the side
hustle becomes the full-time job that's
how it is that's just basic math so
basically what i'm saying is plan b
is pretty helpful in the workforce and
also in the bedroom
anyway so that's destiny have a plan b
if you were going to start a side hustle
side hustle david
i know you're a great musician have you
ever thought about what side hustle you
would start for the record this right
here is my side hustle yeah i've worked
in finance insurance sales for 15 years
you know five years ago i was like holy
[ __ ]
i got a lot of money
i can do what i want to do i've been
working remote before people even knew
what working remote was and that's why i
started a little youtube instagram show
that is basically turned into this at
valuetainment so you can't look in the
short term for a side hustle you know
for for longevity for for money making
it's more of like
eventually this will be something maybe
not a year maybe not two years maybe not
five years but eventually it'll be
something and look at us now here on
valuetainment on the southcast so that
was my side hustle and i still have my
full-time job right still doing my
financial sales
uh like everyone's like who's the guy i
was on the phone with all the time
people wheeling and dealing david to you
what's your side hustle if you were
gonna have a side hustle i mean man
that's yeah i don't know i mean i like
uh i like writing content i like doing
this um i think if i have uh like our
boy marcelo who helps write for the
sauce cast shout out he has a lot of
different little clients and side
hustles he does he's got a puzzle galore
yeah exactly so doing something like
that where you know you stick with the
talent and you help them write i think
okay so you've thought about this yeah
yeah absolutely well listen don't quit
your day job stay here for a little
while buddy we need you but you know
have a plan no absolutely i mean the
sign hostile yeah um number three
uh in the cases of the
ordinary people
flipping the script and leveling up uh
number three is
you could always reinvent yourself
here's a story of 38 year old j.d wilson
who was still learning how to budget
imagine if he learned that when he was
in his 20s he'd be a billionaire like
david amen so this guy jd wilson he shut
down his events company during uh kovid
he sold off most of his stuff and he
moved from new jersey where gerard's
from to hawaii to teach third grade
full disclosure i taught second grade my
first my last job before
starting my financial job rewarding
amazing awesome loved it
would never work for that kind of pay
again in my life anyway hawaii is
definitely more expensive than new
jersey but not by much
um but this guy wilson because he's
learning how to budget is making it work
so basically he's saying that aside from
his rent groceries and student loan
payments the inevitable student loan
payment he doesn't spend on much else
he's basically embracing that minimalist
lifestyle minimalist i'm kind of a
minimalist i'm not a
i'm definitely the oldest millennial and
i'm definitely kind of
of a
a minimalist
i don't you know
i could afford a rolex i don't buy one i
could afford a car i uber everywhere you
got to do things different like our
friends the akrons that uh yeah you know
go around in an rv so this guy's got his
uh
minimalist lifestyle going on right
there uh but basically he loves his new
community in hawaii this guy's story and
he's basically figured out what he wants
for the rest of his life basically the
goal is this you can't be afraid to
switch it up you might be someone
watching this in new jersey hating your
job not sure what's going on next thing
you know you live in hawaii having some
fun in the sun doing luaus with hot
chicks
it's just like that just like that a
chain you're teaching third grade next
thing you know you beat a kindergartner
teacher the two of you are raising two
little tikes living around in hawaii
good for you guys invite me to the
wedding boom there it is blink of an eye
blink of an eye
uh number four
we talk about here uh is you need to
invest in yourself you're the the best
investment you could ever make in your
life is in yourself david you know this
so this is a story about when coveted
hit new york city in uh march of 2020
when this
god
pandemic that never ceases to end um
began emma sadler she lost her job as a
restaurant manager and she said i'm
getting out of the industry completely
so she invested in herself she decided
to take a three-month user experience
boot camp course that cost her
12 g's talk about an investment in
yourself god right so she had saved up
some money she was probably collecting
unemployment wink wink collecting
stimulus checks another wink wink
and she invested that 12 grand rather
than to gucci or louis purses or
traveling she invested into a course a
three month user experience boot camp
course that basically helped her secure
her job in a totally
different
field now she earns 60 grand a year as a
designer with the potential to take home
six figures as she moves up the
proverbial corporate ladder so you david
you me are your best investment oh
you're your belief yeah yeah yeah i know
that you spend a lot of money grooming
your mustache it's a big deal for you
with that mustache you've got gels
you've got creams you've got lotions
oils that's the thing and yourself yeah
it's a big deal yeah yeah i'm actually
85 years old i invest a lot in skin
creams and regimens to make me look
younger but you know we'll do what we
can do i see louis alpha here going ham
in the comment section good for you
um
and last but not least number five and
this is a very ironic on a money show
saskatch saved that money all we talked
is money
but number five is money isn't
everything what what what what what
yeah
so this dude jason lee believed that
earning six figures would prove that he
was a success this was something that he
had ingrained into his mentality from a
young child you make six figures you're
a success but basically he graduated
college got a consulting gig that paid
him a hundred grand and you know what
david he hated it and he hated his life
but he loved all that he loved 100 but
he hated his job so he leaves the
consulting gig he launches a non-profit
with his brother all right you're
working with your brother but you know
what they say about non-profits
you don't make a profit that's a problem
but now he makes decent money i don't
know what decent is but not six figures
anymore but he says the fulfillment he
finds in his work is well worth the pay
cut i get
that you know they say love what you do
you'll never work a day in your life all
right yeah uh you hate what you do
you're gonna hate your life yeah okay so
if it's just for the money
it's probably not gonna last too long
right so you ever worked at a job you're
just like do it i can't frickin do this
anymore yeah absolutely miserable here
no matter what the if the money was good
or bad whatever just can't do it anymore
right
but yeah i also think it's what you make
of it like for instance life settlements
wasn't something you loved zero clue but
but there's parts of that my business i
like
i like negotiating right i like dealing
with people i like networking i like
salesmanship but exactly i like easier
and i like providing value to the
customer the reason that i'm successful
in my business is i'm on a
referral-based business you would not
believe how many people call me up and
they're like hey adam this is bill mcgee
i got your number from a friend of my
financial advisor uh joe sally he says
that you're the best i'm like he's lying
to you buddy
but it's constant referrals and i like
that i like that part of the business
and i like the money that i make sure
yeah but if i hated talking with people
and interacting with people and doing
deals i left the business a long time
ago it's not like i wake up every day
and be like
i love life insurance but it's a means
to him yeah but
in a sense it's like you applied
yourself to this and you got good at it
and you started liking it yes because
your give a [ __ ] level was pretty high
give a [ __ ] level theme of the size cast
if you for some reason
just didn't give a [ __ ] about it clearly
but you're good at all you just yeah
it's like you're never going to get to
that point of liking it if you don't
give a [ __ ] about it sometimes it's the
risk of reward the risk and reward the
rewards actually make very good money
yeah you know the risk is like you know
the annoying stuff is i did do cold
calling for years and grind and sales
and dealing with annoying people that i
want to talk to or whatever
but it's worth it yeah i mean
sometimes you have to just push through
the suck like gerard says embrace the
suck for a little bit it gets better
kind of the whole point yeah right yeah
exactly so
yeah what's the point here of this of
this episode here are five people
everyday people we just talked about
jeff bezos and pitbull and drake and
meek mill and my girl deal lipa and we
flipped it now we're talking about five
normal people who are basically
reinventing their life and changing what
they were doing you're unhappy you're
you got a hundred grand of student uh
loan uh student debt to pay you're
living in an rv good for you the acpons
you uh you're not happy with your job or
you're not being fulfilled boom you
start a youtube consulting business side
hustle you're you're not happy in new
jersey you move to freaking hawaii
you're teaching elementary school good
for you now you're hanging out with the
kids you want to you know you lose your
job you invest 12 grand that you get
from the government or you had saved up
whatever boom now you got a new career
or if you even if you're making money
and you're miserable you work in a
career that you actually love and you're
fulfilled even if you're making less
yeah but these are five people everyday
people
that flip the script i love the phrase
flip the script yeah
it's cause it's like you're going a
certain direction
you're not happy with it
flip that script flip that script bro
flip that script we gotta add the
courage to flip that script a lot of
people are just uh
they're scared to flip it yeah they're
like you know what i
just i don't i can't move i can't move
out of my house and move into an rv what
am i crazy
it's risk reward bro it's risk reward we
have a friend here and i told him hey
man you got to flip the script uh
there's uh what is it
certain person who's in the corner
office over there corner office you know
and he was kind of friends in a friend
zone situation with the with the lady
okay and i was like look bruh
you're like one date away from getting
friend zoned completely you
never a good situation yeah you know
what you gotta do
you gotta flip that script flip that
script there's a stupid audience script
and i've flipped over the table right
now
and he flipped the script he told her
look here's how i feel here's what i
want to do
he went in for a kiss whatever she
kissed him back bingo bengal now they're
dating six months who knows what's going
to happen you get a little different the
script little cupid wings but the time
the the the time that i told him to flip
the script
and like
the next day
and like even that date do you know how
like the risk reward like you know how
like weird he felt he's gonna you know
he's getting about the friend zone oh my
god yeah but now he's dating the girl
good for him same story for all these
five people right here they're miserable
in their jobs they don't like they don't
want to be there they're not like what
they're living they don't they want to
flip the script they did it
most people are too scared to flip the
screen talk is money all we talk is
money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke